tous les observateurs ont constaté
l'extrême cordialité qui a marqué la
visite du chancelier herart à Paris en
compagnie de C de ses ministres une
visite qui devait comporter 2 an
entretient en tête à-tête avec le
général de Gaulle à l'Élysée et un large
tour d'horizon entre les gouvernements
des deux
[Musique]
pays une visite de travail qui entrait
dans le cadre du traité de coopération
de 1963 et dont le chancelier s'est
déclaré particulièrement
satisfait dans le rapprochement
franco-allemand le RIN a retrouvé
aujourd'hui sa vocation de grande artère
de communication européenne et voici que
l'aménagement de la Melle vient de lui
donner un prolongement vers la Lorine
deux automoteurs Renant l'un allemand le
RIN rour 8 l'autre français le kantenac
muni d'un radar permettant la navigation
de nuit ou par brouillard ont effectué
ensemble le premier voyage commercial de
celin Saville au passage de l'écluse de
palzem la foule luxembourgeoise a salué
comme il le méritait l'événement que
constitue la mise en service de cette
voie nouvelle ouverte entre l'Allemagne
le Luxembourg et la France la
canalisation de la Moselle ne
pose-t-elle pas le premier jalon de la
liaison Rin rô du grand axe navigable
nord- sudud
APAC c'est l'écluse des trois frontières
celle où l'on prend conscience de
l'aspect collectif
franco-germano-lxembourgeois d'une œuvre
qui a été accomplie en 7 ans sur 270 km
des dérivations ont été créées des éclus
édifiés le chenal a été creusé dans le
lit de la rivière à une profondeur de
2,90 et au mois de mai des bateaux de
1500 tonnes les équivalent d'un train et
demi de marchandise et des convois
poussés comportant deux barges de 1600
tonnes l'équivalent de TR trains de
marchandis pourront s'engager sur cette
voie de gabarit internationale alors
thville et la cidérurgie Lorine auront
accès direct au bassin de la rou et au
port de
Rotterdam les massacres de limasol ont
amené la crise cypriote à son point
culmin
pendant plusieurs jours les rues de la
2è ville de Lille ont été le théâtre de
violent combat des Grecs armé ont
entrepris un véritable nettoyage du
quartier turc utilisant même des
buldozers
blindés désormais c'est l'état d'alerte
permanent entre les deux communautés le
recours au Conseil de sécurité n'était
plus évitable après l'échec auprès de
Monseigneur macarios du numéro 2 de la
diplomatie américaine monsie George B
celui-ci avait tenté de faire accepter
la présence d'une force du commonws pour
relayer les troupes britanniques à
l'heure où le port de famagust vivait
dans la hantise d'une intervention
directe de la flotte
[Musique]
turque l'U parviendra-t-elle à éviter
aux Grecs et aux Turcs de continuer à
[Musique]
s'entretuer voici une année qui nous
offre un jour de plus un jour de plus
dit un verbe africain ne fait pas courir
l'éléphant mais que faire d'un jour de
plus madame que pensez-vous du 29
février et bien monsieur pour moi c'est
une chance c'est la période justement de
mes vacances ce qui me permet de passer
une journée de PL avec mes
enfants bien moi ça m'ennuie assez parce
que je suis né le 29 février alors d'un
seul coup du jour au lendemain j'ai 4 an
de plus oh moi je trouve ça très
pratique au contraire pour les cadeaux
bien ça me fera un jour de plus qui me
coûter aussi cher que les autres un jour
de plus c'est une chance de plus avec la
tranche spéciale j'espère devenir
millionnaire
se faire entoler au mois de février ça
fait un jour de
[Musique]
robe la vie moderne étant ce qu'elle est
on pourrait croire les pauvres citadins
voués à une perpétuelle surexcitation
nerveuse il existe pourtant un remède
vieux du reste le monde capable de
sauver de leur insomnie les victimes du
siècle de la
précipitation regardez bien cet homme ne
croyez pas qu'il marche comme vous et
moi il rythme sa respiration sur ses pas
il contrôle chacun de ses mouvements il
pratique le hata yoga voilà le grand M
lâché et nous avons demandé à Monsieur
Ferrer de nous en dévoiler les
mystères pour parenir à réaliser ce que
le yoga prétend nous faire réaliser et
bien il y a plus plusur manières
notamment il y a le at yoga le at
yoga c'est c'est une forme de yoga qui
utilise comme tremplin l'énergie a
signifie achat signifie l'énergie
positive
thch signifie l'énergie négative voilà
qui est clair et à partir de là 800
postures permettent de contrôler et
d'éduquer le moindre muscle le moindre
élément du corps
humain citons le porvotana autrement dit
la chandelle qui a pour vertu
particulière de faciliter
l'élocution le vipari takarini est une
posture de repos qui apporte déteinte et
lucidité chacune de ces positions
toujours difficiles exige est-il besoin
de le préciser une concentration totale
autant de pauses qui sont autant de
recettes à chacune des complications des
difficultés de notre vie agitée tout
peut être résolu même le trac j'ai vu
cela surtout dans le monde des des
artistes dans le monde des élèves qui
vont passer leur bac et oui ils sont le
trac mais ce trac se corrige facilement
enfin pour yogi se corrige facilement en
en agissant sur le centre d'énergie
cardiaque
chakra saluons donc aujourd'hui les
vertus séculaires hautement calmantes du
hata
yoga
[Musique]
c'est sous le signe de la bonne humeur
et des fcé de Marielle guatchel l'enfant
terrible du ski alpin que s'est déroulé
la réception offerte à l'Hôtel Matignon
par le Premier ministre monsieur George
Pompidou aux membres de l'équipe
Française de Ski pour une fois on avait
oublié le protocole dans l'oster maison
de la rue de
varen mais ce n'était là qu'un entract
pour les jeunes skieurs français qui dès
le lendemain reprenaient la compétition
sur les pistes de Garmish parten kirion
en Allemagne de l'Ouest où se sont
déroulé les épreuves du
Kandar Marielle guchel a profité de
cette nouvelle occasion pour prouver
qu'elle est bien la meilleure skieuse du
monde elle a gagné le combiné tout
[Musique]
commebr une petite ombre cependant sur
cette victoire Marielle a dû céder la
première place du slalom spécial à
l'américaine jeanbert comme elle dit
elle-même il faut bien qu'elle laisse
tout de même de temps en temps une
consolation à ses
rivales Jean-Claude Kili le faux fiancé
de Mariel guatchel c'est le grand
champion de de mains dont on attendait
pourtant un exploit un peu avant la
lettre à
hsbck il n'y a pas eu d'exploit aux Jeux
Olympiques où Jean-Claude kilily a
accumulé les faux
[Musique]
pas la malchance ne pouvait pas durer
indéfiniment et à garmich au slalom
géant du candard il a montré ce qu' il
savait faire regardez-le bien ce
skilleur là c'est l'un des champions
olympiques de
demain la porte des grandes victoires
est enfin ouverte à Jean-Claude Kiri
déjà prêt à assurer la relève des
bonslieux et des
[Musique]
Lacroix
I